so I produced a book filled with
illustrations there's one on page 16 and
17 of two boys standing looking up at a
huge wall that they're considering
climbing over and going on an adventure
and of all the illustrations in the book
this is sort of I think defining of my
life and I think it's the most exciting
one which is we all imagined brighter
futures and it's as if we're standing at
this wall we don't know how to get over
it we don't know how to get to the other
side we don't know how to get what we
want and to me it's the choice to climb
the wall it's the choice to find a way
around the wall that is what
distinguishes the innovators from
everybody else that's what distinguishes
the doers from everybody else it's what
distinguishes those who find what
they're looking for those who find
happiness but the purpose of the book is
to remind us that we cannot climb that
wall by ourselves that if we want to
find that brighter future if we want to
change our lot it is for us to find
someone who will go with us
so I'm someone who will catch us if we
fall down someone who will help us up
over the wall and it's these two kids
standing looking up over the wall what's
most important is that they're doing it
together
you